[Música]
[Aplausos]
la crisis y la incertidumbre son
maestras que miden constantemente el
nivel de grandeza que tenemos los seres
humanos
son las dificultades son las
frustraciones
el área donde nos damos cuenta de que
estamos hechos
la educación es la herramienta más
potente que tiene la cultura para ir
desarrollando talentos y recursos en las
generaciones jóvenes
la pandemia y el confinamiento ha sido
un examen
que ha sacado a flote el estado actual
de la educación que les estamos dando a
nuestros niños y adolescentes
y en muchas ocasiones hemos reprobado
ese examen
es por eso que es indispensable que
actualmente nos demos cuenta
que la crisis y la incertidumbre no son
fenómenos puntuales atribuibles en este
caso a la pandemia y el confinamiento la
crisis y la incertidumbre son cíclicas
en el ser humano
y si son situaciones recurrentes la
educación debe considerar en su
currículo psicológico esa asignatura
dolorosa de cómo enfrentar la crisis y
la incertidumbre
estamos pues en una situación
privilegiada la escuela debe aprender
como reformar su sistema a fin de que
realmente se convierta en escuela para
la vida
el estar tan centrados en asignaturas en
objetivos medibles observables nos ha
hecho miopes y no nos ha permitido
observar que hay otros ingredientes en
la vida del ser humano que por ser
espirituales o casi invisibles
no los tenemos que manejar
es por eso que es una oportunidad la que
tenemos ahora
y aprender
que las crisis son instructivas no
destructivas
todo depende que estamos haciendo para
enseñarles a nuestros niños y
adolescentes esta asignatura dolorosa
pero necesaria
desde abril de 2020
con un equipo trabajamos un screening de
bienestar emocional empezaba la
manifestación severa de la pandemia y
estábamos confinados
nos preocupaba saber
como estaba en las herramientas
espirituales de los niños y adolescentes
preparadas para hacer frente a esta
situación que se antojaba ya desde abril
del año pasado como algo más largo en el
tiempo
y desarrollamos en la plataforma hábil
mind esta herramienta que mide
cómo se encuentran los elementos de
gestión de las emociones en qué estado
encontramos los aliados del bienestar
emocional y cuáles serían esas
manifestaciones conductuales dependiendo
del nivel logrado en ese es crítico
logramos una aplicación masiva en muy
muy poco tiempo
y ahora quiero presentarles estos
resultados para méxico donde hasta el 27
de noviembre cuando hice un corte de la
estadística
habíamos encontrado 78700 siete
respuestas de alumnos desde preescolar
hasta la secundaria
en ese screening en ese test de
bienestar emocional mediamos tres
grandes bloques o tres grandes
componentes del bienestar emocional
con frecuencia esta palabra de bienestar
es un poco aérea o un poco difícil de
definir sin embargo es lo que entendemos
con frecuencia cuando hablamos de
felicidad es el huevo bin el bien ser el
bien está
el primer bloque que medimos eran las
emociones causales que se generaban a
partir de una crisis o de una
incertidumbre y repito las crisis y las
incertidumbres son cíclicas aparecen
constantemente en nuestra vida y por lo
tanto si son parte esencial de la
experiencia humana hace falta preparar a
los niños y adolescentes a hacer frente
con dignidad y con respeto
ahí medimos la gestión que tienen los
alumnos del miedo
luego lo expresaré les presentaré los
resultados en esos cuatro bloques que
hicimos de niños de preescolar niños de
1º a 3º de primaria niños de cuarto a
sexto de primaria y adolescentes de
secundaria
el segundo componente de la emoción
causal era la gestión de la ira
cómo reaccionamos cuando algo no sucede
como esperamos
el tercer factor es la gestión de la
tristeza el dolor que experimentamos
ante un bien perdido o que se va a
perder
y el cuarto elemento es la gestión de la
ansiedad la angustia el estrés que se
deriva cuando el espíritu humano se
siente sobrepasado se siente abrumado
este es el primer bloque el segundo se
refiere a los factores de protección que
hemos desarrollado en los niños estos
factores de protección son herramientas
psicológicas emocionales que les hemos
enseñado y que el niño ha asimilado para
hacer frente a las situaciones difíciles
de la vida
una de ellas es el optimismo que tanto
nuestros niños saben enfrentar la
escasez la dificultad la frustración con
un espíritu optimista sabiendo que son
más grandes que sus problemas
el segundo factor de protección medido
es la autoestima el autoconcepto que
tiene nuestros niños y adolescentes
la el aprecio que tienen a sus
capacidades y la confianza en sí mismos
medimos también la motivación intrínseca
que tanto los niños y adolescentes
tienen motivos personales para enfrentar
sobre todo lo que resulta difícil la
rutina el trabajo la responsabilidad
y el cuarto elemento de protección que
me dimos fue la expresividad emocional
si los niños y adolescentes tienen la
capacidad de verbalizar sus emociones de
construir un relato que les permita
gestionar las experiencias que van
logrando a lo largo de su vida
y finalmente el tercer polo de medición
fueron las manifestaciones conductuales
que van a ser la salida que tiene en el
niño o adolescente los dos polos
anteriores tanto la gestión de las
emociones como los factores de
protección y ahí sobre todo nos
centramos en cinco manifestaciones una
la alteración del sueño cuando no se
equilibran las gestiones emocionales y
no hay suficientes factores de
protección se alteran funciones vitales
en el ser humano uno de ellos es el
sueño el otro va a ser la alimentación a
veces hay un ansia por comer o se pierde
el apetito
y un tercer factor que nos resultó
especialmente interesante fue el abuso
de pantallas que es como la evasión la
salida más concreta a no querer
centrarse en sí mismo porque se ve vacío
se ve huérfano de herramientas para
poder enfrentar la dificultad
e incorporamos también el aislamiento
social cuando alguien se aísla para
rodear su dolor y su pena empieza un
proceso autodestructivo que puede
terminar en una depresión
y finalmente la agresividad
o las conductas disruptivas chicos que
cuando son presa de emociones negativas
que no saben gestionar empiezan a
sacarlas con manifestaciones de ira
destructiva
estos tres polos de medición nos
sirvieron para obtener un perfil de cómo
se encuentran nuestros niños y
adolescentes en méxico quiero
comentarles que este screening de
bienestar emocional se aplicó en españa'
y en prácticamente todos los países de
américa latina sin embargo lo que les
voy a presentar ahora de resultados se
refiere a lo que obtuvimos en mexico
aquí tienen los resultados en preescolar
nos salió como uno de los elementos
importantes a cuidar no voy a darles el
resultado de todos los factores porque
sería muy largo y simplemente me
concreto a presentarles aquellos que
requieren especial atención
no sabe que los niños de preescolar
tienen al miedo como uno de los focos de
atención que tenemos nosotros que
atender el miedo es la emoción quizá más
destructiva para el aprendizaje porque
concentra la energía en las partes más
primitivas del cerebro orientadas a la
supervivencia y quita esa energía a los
procesos superiores del pensamiento
el niño no puede aprender cuando está
bajo la influencia del miedo y no la
sabe gestionar no le hemos enseñado a
gestionar el miedo
en esta edad
el segundo factor que salió como
necesario de atención fue la
alimentación
quiere decir que el niño en estas
situaciones de cierto desequilibrio lo
primero que le afecta es su sentido de
alimentación
empieza el niño a perder el orden en los
alimentos y a buscar sustitutos de
bienestar psicológico a través de
gratificaciones corporales es cuando
empieza un desajuste en la alimentación
en el caso de primaria de 1º a 3º
encontramos nuevamente el miedo como
foco de atención
sigue apareciendo como una necesidad
importante para la familia y para la
escuela la atención a la gestión del
miedo
pero encontramos aquí otra necesidad
diferente en primero y tercero y en la
motivación la motivación intrínseca
ciertamente la escuela y la familia no
ha sabido cómo desarrollar motivación
intrínseca y acude a los elementos más
primitivos de motivación que suelen ser
el premio o el castigo pero eso es
chantaje o soborno no es motivación
intrínseca
en el caso de cuarto a sexto de primaria
el panorama se complica mucho
encontramos más necesidades de atención
a deficiencias en la gestión de la
crisis y la incertidumbre
nuevamente el miedo nos llama la
atención como necesidad a cuidar
además aquí aparece que los niños de
cuarto a sexto no tienen ese aprendizaje
a expresar sus emociones de manera
adecuada
no encuentran el interlocutor la escucha
generosa la mirada compasiva ante lo que
un niño puede estar viviendo
alteraciones en el sueño los niños de
cuarto a sexto en esta medición
nos anuncian que si el sueño se altera
se van automáticamente a repercutir en
otras áreas del aprendizaje y de la
conducta
y además
la afición a pantallas lúdicas
que es diferente a cuando utilizamos las
pantallas la informática para trabajo
para aprendizaje aquí es el uso o el
abuso de pantallas lúdicas
aparece también como una necesidad
es que en secundaria
ya con adolescentes el miedo
vuelve a aparecer y entonces ya parece
que es algo cíclico con lo cual
deducimos que la familia y la escuela no
le proporcionan a los niños y
adolescentes esa percepción de la
realidad que vea más que una amenaza una
oportunidad
aparece también en los adolescentes un
problema de motivación
y además la autoestima baja
con lo cual vamos viendo qué
en un panorama de esta naturaleza los
retos educativos son importantes pero
son insoslayables
la escuela es la escuela para la vida y
no solamente para atender áreas
cognitivas o áreas académicas es un reto
integral
es el ser humano que necesita aprender a
vivir y enfrentar sobre todo aquellas
situaciones más complejas o más
difíciles
este examen sobre esta asignatura
importante del bienestar emocional de
nuestros niños nos dice
que necesitamos repetir aclarar e
iniciar muchos procesos hasta ahora
ignorados
el aspecto de las crisis nos ayuda a
mejorar
no podemos atribuir a las crisis las
causas de nuestros fracasos
porque eso significa que estamos
ignorando el talento y el respeto más
profundo a nuestra riqueza
nos detecta la pereza para innovar para
que nuestra escuela y nuestra familia se
orienten más a enseñar elementos
esenciales para vivir
la crisis es un desafío
y sin desafíos la vida es una rutina
mortal
si no aprendemos a superar crisis no
tenemos mérito
la familia sobreprotectora está
cancelando esta capacidad en los niños y
adolescentes para superar las crisis no
solamente hay que esperarlas hay que
propiciar las para que nos sirva de
entrenamiento y que nuestros niños y
adolescentes aprendan a obtener el
conocimiento de su grandeza interior
este es el reto
derivado de las crisis y la
incertidumbre
y es que a fin de cuentas la crisis la
incertidumbre que es instructiva no es
[Aplausos]